hi everyone this is Jerry and this is
another live blitz game I just want to
seek out for somebody mm or a grater
okay this is a game against somebody by
the name of OLC it's on Knight f3 Knight
f6 pretty flexible move I'm just gonna
set out to but this might turn into an
Enzo Indian or maybe not I'll just go
with trying to establish a pawn on d5
this is just a simple development
develop my King side pieces get castled
I don't want to capture on this square
right away I want to first wait for this
Bishop to move before I do that I'll
make a knight move I'm not sure if I
should go one or two squares for my pawn
here white is delaying this Bishop move
he wants me to maybe take here prior to
this Bishop moving so let's see pawn b6
on c5 go upon No
yeah pawn to b6 just preparing my Bishop
get out along this diagonal I'll have
further control over efore alright so
why do I take my knight or pawn I
probably do pawn bishop here bearing
down on h7 off to be careful of this
square this bishop is definitely better
placed on this square you know of these
two squares e2 and e3
I'm eetu you would do that if you're
worried about you know my bishop maybe
coming out here to do some sort of a pin
but that's not the case here alright so
c5 Bishop b7 thinking c5 is what's
called for here c5 yeah alright Bishop
b7 rook here is a good move placing it
opposite the Queen do I close it up do I
take right now he's getting ready to
take here
and if I take take take and then he's
gonna win upon all right so there's
there's pressure gets here indirectly as
a result of this move so what to do pawn
to h6 let's see yeah upon h6 attack the
bishop don't know him don't allow him to
grab the h7 pawn all right so rook c8
seems the right way to go about things
oh no all right so I'm gonna pin how to
get out of it
probably just this I don't know
rook c7 Knight here could be annoying
hmm I'm gonna take here let's open up
this file prior to moving my rook here
so now the knight can't come here cuz
it's in a pin so move order matters
Knight here
I think Knight here is a good choice or
maybe first this and then here maybe not
hmm
here I'm on this Bishop Knight e4 Bishop
takes Queen takes and then he's got
stuff going on against my night on d7
all right so what to do
take Knight takes Knight pawn takes
knight Knight here Bishop takes Queen
takes yeah we'll go for take here first
night here he can't take with the night
because he's still in this pin so Bishop
takes Queen takes I'm off of this file
or that move which I didn't expect all
right let's take care oh that's just a
blip this is a blunder yeah he doesn't
he's in a pin here that was a mistake I
think our now queen yeah maybe it's not
a mistake hmm Bishop here Bishop no fish
up to this square yeah I'm up I think
Bishop here will ultimately lead to my
obtaining a rook on the seventh ring
Bishop here rook takes Queen Bishop
takes Queen rook takes or a King takes
rook they takes bishop and then rook to
DC D - hmm I think I'm gonna go for that
yeah and a half - rook takes Bishop
takes Queen
orgeous resignation Wow so why did he
resign that quick I think that was a
premature resignation I think he could
just play actually how do we get an
examine mode here there we go all right
so what in the world went on here let's
bring this up to
the resignation point right here you
resigned I think he could just take my
queen and now what Bishop takes Queen
rook takes rook King takes rook Knight
takes bishop and he's up upon I could go
here I have pressure on the seventh rank
but that was probably not the point to
be resigning in I guess he simply
miscalculated and as a result I lucked
out again so any questions or comments
feel free to leave them on YouTube
thanks so much bye